greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday June 12th the podcast is
brought to you by pushy listen Cushie
is the best bidet out there portable
bidet that you could get your hands on
you're asking me Joey what the hell is
that tushy tushy sprays water directly
into your [ __ ] and removes the poop
completely sure not sitting on bacteria
that leads to nasty things like
hemorrhoids yeast infections UTI
h e ass holes and skid marks but des is
a common in the rest of the world but
they saves you money on toilet paper
still you use a little toilet paper to
pat dry but the amount is negligible you
understand me why would you want to
[ __ ] claw get your toilets till she
sprays your ass with fresh water that's
not toilet water either it connects to a
water supply behind your toilet to spray
your dirty [ __ ] parts clean with
fresh water it's the same water you
brush your teeth now for Father's Day
twitch is running a little special it's
an upgrade you're gonna get a bidet some
bamboo bum towels a travel case and a
t-shirt but do me a favor it all starts
with you by going - hello - she's calm
right now
go to hell old touchy look at all the
days starting at $69 you get 10% off
when you go - hello - she calm and
you're pressing code Church CH you are
CH that's 10% off your bidet for Dad you
want dad's [ __ ] to smell like a
[ __ ] bouquet of [ __ ] roses start
with hello - she calm right now press in
church and get 10% off your order the
church is also brought to you by on it
when it comes to supplements there's one
of the only companies I trust why
because they stand behind their products
go to Anna comrade now take a great
selection take a look at the great
selection of supplements from the
protein powder to the shroom take a moon
to the chute export you make the judge
you read up on those quadricep mushrooms
a little [ __ ] they are but anyway when
you go to on it you see something that
you want do yourself a favor
you're looking to start a new life
you're looking I can't focus alpha brain
is the way to go going on it calm right
now you see something you like on the
I'll press in church and get 10% off
your order its that quickly and it gets
delivered the house who's better than us
who's better than you nobody we kick
this [ __ ] mule oh it's that just
brought me back man oh my god that's
when I had hair I'm not even joking you
don't wash I loved what was never done
again it oh my god they invoke and vogue
went to go see them at the Aladdin
theater did you ring up I went and saw
SWV to where I was so I was living in
Vegas at the time so I was I was
addicted to all of that that whole New
Jack Swing movement came out of New York
Virginia Beach New York Teddy Riley you
know when he collaborated with SWV that
all those beats right there just [ __ ]
amazing that's that that era will never
come back I mean they try it like Bruno
started coming up with this you know
with his 24-karat you know that was a
throwback to that movement but that
movement was so special because it was
kind of like the separation from arm be
of the 80s the traditional you know the
the new additions and all that and then
and it went to like this hip hop feel it
was just like this that Street vibe you
know to me mary j blige SWV guy black
street like it was just raw you grew up
on
I loved it man Jodeci are you kidding me
Jodeci was tremendous do one of my
favorite I'm sorry to keep talking Joey
Butler alright when I met I'll be sure
at Jerry's deli
I literally paid for his meal and uh and
uh oh it was I'll be sure and uh Heavy D
and I paid for the meal and I literally
walked up and it was just like hey man
thank you for everything like you
changed music you guys changed music and
thank you for that and and that's that
was on that was my way of saying thank
you they always say never meet your
heroes but I had to do that like that
that music right there was everything to
me that's all I had you know all I did
was listen Oh rock music I mean I did
but I'm more of the if it's a hit then
then I gravitate towards it like when
ac/dc comes out with you know back in
black or you know me Pearl Jam it you
know I mean a that's whenever it's like
that thinner then I gravitate towards it
but I I don't go deep into the b-sides
of it I'm a Beatles fan I'm a you
you know I mean I'm I'm not rock a more
of that RB soul I'm just blown away that
so many comedians come in here you throw
on music and they [ __ ] spill their
guts yeah why didn't you get into music
you are like sort of a DJ I love it man
you know I think also cuz Filipino my
Filipino side my mom's side it's it's
all about music it's little my sister
became a singer in Vegas for 20 years
she was a lounge act you know that was
my first time actually tasting a Vegas
stage was when my sister was in between
a set and she goes hey my brother does
comedy and I went up at the Stardust
remember the Stardust before they tore
that [ __ ] down so I went up at the start
us in was a bar they were playing a bar
this is so Vegas right here it was a bar
and behind the bar where they put the
the bottles was her band like they
literally gave her the the this this
this desk right here was there stays he
had a [ __ ] drum two guitars and my
sister singing a lead with the the
guitar player and and they were doing it
they were doing four sets a night you
know I mean from 8:00 to 1:00 a.m. and
then and she brought me up one night and
I remember I was you know I was being
dirty it was my first you know I was you
know how it is when you first started it
was just dirty dirty dirty and then the
the the pit boss came and he was like
hey get him off the stage what the [ __ ]
can't be talking like that we got people
gambling but that was my first taste of
a Vegas stage and I was that was it I
was addicted now you grew up and see it
I grew up in Tacoma which is 45 right
Tacoma which is like 45 minutes from
Seattle never did copy up there no man I
told everyone I was gonna be one though
no I used to sign a phone book I was
living with my roommate William and I
used to sign the phone book just in this
back this is how old I am
just for your listeners I'm very [ __ ]
old forty-eight you know ah thanks man
and I was I was signing the phone book
you know just sign it sign it's a nice
on every page phone you know that that's
back then when people need her phone
books you know we didn't have her phones
back there you need the [ __ ] phone
book I remember he was looking for like
something in the phobias like yo stop
[ __ ] sign in the phone book
what are you gonna be famous said that
to me and I was like yeah you'll see
you'll see yeah I'm practicing my
signature now I was joking but actually
underneath bitterly no man I was really
and I was actually resented him for that
I remember I used to you know we don't
talk anymore by the way William and he's
my best friend all the way through but
that's when you when you realize when
you get to that that fork in the road
you're just like you you're so you're so
[ __ ] driven that that that [ __ ] isn't
gonna help me
you know I mean that kind of [ __ ]
what are you gonna be famous that that's
not gonna help me that that little
whatever you're saying right there does
not help me that brings me down so I
don't need that let me go and that's
what I did I let him go it was a sad day
my sister you know still talks to him
but but I don't wanna I don't want to I
don't want to go back to that like I'm
so [ __ ] focused and I just want the
right pieces around me I don't have time
for that [ __ ] you know you know I'm
sorry I didn't mean to go oh I want you
I want you so when you come on yes I
want you so thanks tell me what they
want you to hear yeah I want you to tell
me what's in your soul you know it's
weird that you would do that
subconsciously yeah but personally you
knew what you were doing I didn't have
the balls yeah because I would have
gotten too disappointed if I would have
failed
mmm the disappointment would have been
too much yeah I want more oh I'm not
paying attention so I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm doing but did you ever
watch the dirty 4:30 with Jim Valvano oh
yeah man practice you made him cut the
Nets
yeah to practice being champions so
means that right there you look at that
and go how come I never thought of that
yeah man I don't cut the Nets to see how
it feels to cut the Nets down mm-hmm
they got a taste of that that went into
their subconscious and it just go they
manifest and it works it works
you know what's crazy Joey is how he did
that in the 80s like like right now a
lot of people are kind of in touch with
that now about manifestation and really
believing in it and telling yourself and
but imagine back then when that wasn't
out know there was only a few people
that really thought like that you know I
mean and they did it and that he was one
of them man I don't even think he told
people yeah
cancer didn't know you know me I don't
even know if he actually knew or or what
but I think he kept that to himself and
so right and it's just like [ __ ]
amazing it's just so amazing that that I
don't know it's just it's cool to see
people manifest their future and and and
and really taken a hold of whatever it
is that they're passionate about five
what's that dancer that went bankrupt
and then whatever it doesn't matter you
know MC MC Hammer used to sell albums
you know Comedy Store yeah people will
say he would back his car up
they sell albums Oh bro I I was watching
a documentary on Hammer Tahoe yeah you
are good Joey that's true yeah because I
was watching the documentary and he had
a deal with Capitol Records and he
turned it down I don't I'm gonna make up
a number let's just say it was a million
dollar deal okay which is a lot of money
for a rapper back then right and he
turned it down cuz he said I can sell
more of them out of the back of my trunk
at outside of a nightclub he would
literally take his single that he
produced himself go to a nightclub beg
the DJ to play or tip him a little bit
of money make him play it in rotation
and once that song came on he went to
the floor and just started dancing
because he knew everyone was gonna watch
him dance and then literally he would
just wait outside and as the the
nightclub would close he would just
stand at the back of his car and people
would walk up to him you know who the
guy that was dancing was like you know
that was my song boom and he'd sell out
the back of his car that's the [ __ ] you
know all that [ __ ] always affects me
yeah whose touches me Jamie Foxx called
his name Jamie Foxx it sounded like a
girl and he knew he would get stage time
why genius see what this genius thought
proper when you hear amazing when you
hear that [ __ ] you go oh yeah I got a
run I gotta be that slick yeah to run
this game yeah he would go to the comedy
store and you know he put his real name
on him as a guy yeah so he put Jamie
Foxx he thought he was a girl you gotta
be kidding me that's genius and his
grandmother you never saw that actor
studio was grandmother used to make her
play a piano every day oh but he was a
kid yeah how long some day you'll need
this [ __ ]
and he able to play Ray Charles dude
that's the [ __ ] that you sit there and
go man why you have to pay attention
these this is why yeah man all that
stuff but you when you watch Rocky
he didn't manifest himself he went back
with [ __ ] rocky up if you bail cuz I
was watching it the other night
it's such a good movie yeah but think
what changed him the button that changed
him is when he went to the arena and he
told the guy that his shorts will color
the color were wrong on the shorts and
the guy took a pop of a cigar that says
it doesn't really matter I think you're
gonna give us a good fight and he just
looked at Mike it just clicked
yeah and his head oh [ __ ] and he was
half [ __ ] he went back woke up
Adrian yeah
whoa cage you know he told him he was
scared and that was it he went in there
to fight for his debt yeah he said I'm
fighting some like that all those type
of stories or everyday stories that you
have to pay attention to as a young man
you see how to get across that peak yeah
these are little things he had to do up
to about two years ago I thought so
Vesta Stallone was just a lucky guy hmm
and then I started watching the Rambo
started coming on yeah I started
remembering the Rockies and then the
Expendables and go he's up to Rocky
eight yeah I just watched Creed 2 yeah
that's right I didn't think about that
create two is part of the rocky
franchise eight rocky holy [ __ ] I think
it's eight don't get mad at me but think
about what you have to do to create what
he created yeah I created years later
you know you got in general what series
you got the expand you got the other guy
that's got a great series but nobody's
really done with Rocky's four or five
rainbows huh and he's doing Rocky night
yeah and the Expendables yeah he's do
holy [ __ ] Expendables are up to almost
four yeah that's amazing
so here's a guy that's gave away his dog
cause he couldn't feed him whoo here's a
guy that took a script and said no
you're not gonna let
you play rocking though that's like
[ __ ] crazy I didn't even know that no
yeah he fought him to the end like a
hundred grand when they shot that scene
with that but he was a director Iraqi
right no oh I this whole time I thought
he directed run I think I wrote it see
who wrote who directed rocky so then he
director rocky too then right [ __ ] this
whole time I thought he was I think he I
don't think he had juice to like for to
start telling mom oh really
I mean I've been wrong story this is
John G avildsen oh I've been telling the
wrong story man I always thought like
Stallone was one of those wrote it
directed you know I mean I thought Rocky
was his baby
well he's got a little bit of whatever
this past
uh-huh people haven't raised their hand
I just heard a very interesting story
I have heard a story that and my buddy's
gonna kill me for saying that cuz this
is the podcast that Sylvester Stallone
and a script No Sylvester Stallone went
to Bayonne to tranfer Chuck Wepner and
Chuck Wepner I had a notebook with all
his notes in it and when he went to
trained Chuck weaponless trainer told
him no because he had done porn
so Sylvester Stallone took Chuck what
there's no book and he wrote rocky
really yeah Expendables was one of Eddie
Bravo students who wrote it what all
Sylvester Stallone took him to a meeting
so fast I said yes he never heard from
the guy again and one day he's sitting
in his little when a commercial comes on
showing the Expendables so he sued him
and if you remember the Expendables they
said written by so Vestas long they put
that guy's name and he went on to write
Godzilla and some other stuff but the
original story is he got that presented
to sources oh this is crazy
Sylvester Stallone so yeah because it
really doesn't matter at the end of the
day did he have something like that with
rocky - with rocky
something that's what I'm saying that's
a Chuck Wepner oh that's
Chuck oh [ __ ] what there was life I
listen whatever happened you didn't
protect yourself go [ __ ] yourself yeah
you should have known better one the one
you want you should have been prepared
who you're dealing with this in the city
but still he kept it alive you know it's
like when they always said well let's
upward
took a lot of music whoa you know what
man I know what it takes you know it's
like when they got accused of taking
stairway to heaven they probably did
they probably did take that melody but
who's gonna overturn that in today's
world when you hear the first three
chords of stairway to heaven yeah you
know everybody in high school lost a
friend they put that out but you're
gonna reverse it down yeah how many
people got buried with Led Zeppelin's
[ __ ] 400 or whatever have a song that
Atmos yeah for I think mm-hmm they call
it something that how many people got
buried with that Led Zeppelin but these
stories I tell you about Jamie Foxx and
I got a thousand other ones that really
you know Ricky Ricardo yeah was his
parents sent them from Cuba to a private
school because Batista was out of
control in the United States I think in
Cuba out of control yeah and they knew
they were next to be the Batista was
gonna shoot him so they wanted to
protect Ricky Ricardo so he sent Ricky
Ricardo what's his name real-life dance
your dance yeah a private school in
Miami this is before he was desi arnaz
before he was done in Cuba no he was a
kid that sang and played the guitar and
he got him out of that good-looking he
got him out of there but guess who his
schoolmate was in Miami who Capone's son
get out so Christmastime everybody's
going to their respective houses for
Christmas
Cuba kids going I got nowhere to go
Capone's father said your son said
you're coming with me to come to Chicago
it's 1940 then and I saw what a [ __ ]
Cuban was before and this guy walks in
with pointy shoes saying how and Capone
fell in love him and one day he call
Capone and said I want to play this club
in New York the poem made the call and
that's the story are you [ __ ] kidding
me that's a real story real story and
then somewhere
he met Lucille Ball yeah which is even
more crazy crazy crazy opportunities
never ends never and all those type of
stories not before I went to prison
yeah I probably went the three Anthony
Robbins seminars before yeah they've
been victim in jail that's it they just
made my [ __ ] crime game stronger yeah
Anthony Robbins like motivated me to
steal more my way to say it was like
your eyeball saw it and then it
registered in your mind is set off a
certain trigger I don't know what
trigger he set off make good stuff snort
coke every Rob pushed me over the side
that's not one of those calls I couldn't
stop snorting coke you motivated me to
snort luan of a dog you wanna be the
kidnapper [ __ ] I became a
kidnapper
Robert so I don't talk with Anthony
Roberts no way just like I would talk to
him if you paid me yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] sexy refusing he might be going
to jail yeah he's going to jail too
is he some bad but he got like four or
five people accusing him right now yeah
yeah these guys are [ __ ] disgusting I
was just watching this thing on uh on
Instagram it's one of those late-night
worm holes that you get in when you just
start feeding going through the feed and
it was this guy that bought his private
jet from God the kind that the guy that
has the studio uh [ __ ] me Harvey doesn't
know the one that does all the the guy
the what this bad pod right now the one
that does the oh he's what the [ __ ] is
his name he does the yeah man what is
the neither the black actor he plays
that he does the gray wig you know but
better but daya the Medea that what's
the name of that Tyler Perry Tyler Perry
me I'm sorry we cut all that please know
he's in trouble
no he's not he he just sold his plane
the thing is he just sold his plane but
the guy that bought the plane is one of
those
advant of Angeles who asks for money and
those might get money from everybody and
this news reporter went up
it was like hey weird you bought Tyler
Perry's private jet how does that feed
the poor I mean like how does all your
money that you said that you need to
help feed the poor how does that justify
this private jet you just bought from
Tyler Perry any it's just like these
guys are just such [ __ ] creeps you
know I mean it's like when you hear
stories like if a Robin oh I've planes
it's like yeah yeah you hear something
like you know cuz you see Nathan Robbins
and he's motivating people in Buffalo
and then you hear this [ __ ] you're just
like everything you talked about just
went to [ __ ] what is sure yeah and then
and it's just like this evangelist it's
just like you know you here you are
you're you're manipulating people that
are you know that are in need and you
know they're desperate and they're
they're on their last you know whatever
it is and they and they give you their
their doll or whatever it is that you
asked for then you go buy a [ __ ] jet
from Tyler Perry I say [ __ ] you man
religious I mean I mean it's I am with
that when the holiday comes you know how
did you raise your son religious my son
yeah he goes to a Catholic school but I
think it's because my mom's Filipino and
it was me and it's just yeah I mean you
don't listen I'm a Catholic in my heart
well if you think I'm gonna get up on a
Sunday and go sit with those hypocrites
no you're out of your [ __ ] mind no
I'm not gonna go sit and the first three
rows all those guys are cheating on
their waters yeah
oh they're [ __ ] some little
twelve-year-old but it means something
[ __ ] right and you know I feel like
the people who sit closer to the priest
yeah they're the biggest [ __ ] scum
the closer you are people sit in the
first five pews of [ __ ] scum backs
they look crazy through life and they
and they wear the suit and they lie when
I go to church you know that Joey I'm
sorry to interrupt you that is that's
[ __ ] genius thought you're so right
the closer [ __ ] man I've been saying
this forever man it's the people that
that that that put themselves closer to
goodness are the ones that are hiding
[ __ ] alright I call those [ __ ]
magicians you know they're like
modern-day magicians do you know it's
like I'm so evil but here's a smoke
cloud yet I mean and divert the
attention to someone else that's doing
some wrong [ __ ] you know I mean like I'm
not bad look this guy's bad you know
this is people that sit on the soapbox
in and
speech about how bad people are to make
throw the [ __ ] works money and they
take the community yeah man and they do
the whole thing and they invite the
father over for dinner yeah and why I'm
saying this is because in 87 I sold cars
this guy came in once was surance guy
and we started talking when he came in
he was 40 I was 25 he was the chick that
was my age hmm and then looking like
convertible Chrysler's boom I mean with
a Chrysler compatible was big yeah and
then I became friends of the guy I would
call him up and one day he goes you know
I know your father-in-law
I'm Sacred Heart Church and I went to
church that Sunday and who's in the
first [ __ ] Pew that one right there
and everybody's hand next to his fat
overgrown [ __ ] wife that's 400 pounds
and then just shaking hugging people I'm
like this [ __ ] is just being so
funny and I told my father while my
little bus and my father was that guy's
been a piece of [ __ ] for 30 years
no you never tell me nothin he goes I
can't stand he said to the first [ __ ]
roll that's so true like that's like but
that's when I put that but Filipinos
humans you know our country is a mixture
of everybody yeah but he is everybody
who's gotten laid in our country and
left their seat yeah the Chinese Irish
that there's so many different you know
you go to Asia you will find a Gonzalez
and that's the truth that's the truth
you'll find a Santos looking Tony
Gonzalez Filipino yeah my I have a
Gonzalez in my family Gonzalez I have a
dela fourth day in the center I don't
know what Diaz but spelled with an e
yeah in Filipino many years ago he still
talks to me on Facebook the games to the
shows in that crazy it's a [ __ ] crazy
place but the Catholicism level like
Edwin saying once uncle was a priest now
you know he has another than uncle I
went to church every day the people that
Mercy's godparents dead church people
yeah
they don't miss church they drink before
the morning when dominoes need lumpia
yeah and the whole [ __ ] thing
oh yeah everybody's ready mahjong my
show know the carne the the [ __ ]
really good beef yeah asado
asada asada yeah that floppy schiappa
beef tapa yeah but you I don't [ __ ] with
the pigeon no it scares me a little bit
did we eat pigeon Joey yes they do
Filipinos ease pinions you always got
magician
outside the house [ __ ] with sticks we
got [ __ ] we want our pigeons back
protest you see magicians out the
hilarion I will be back you can't eat
are you tensed but my last year when
they made that movie clown yeah about
two weeks later this is not a joke it
was in the paper they had a parade of
thing where a bunch of clowns went down
to the protest that movie because they
were losing work for the summer when we
came out you know about it yes come on
we came out people were cancelling
clowns left to right dad said that's it
enough they went down the well I was
Dangerfield Thousand clowns went
downtown with suits on saying take the
movie out we'll lose the summer work and
[ __ ] because the movie came out and
[ __ ] up people will cancel class
that's funny a [ __ ] get a leg yeah get
a Power Ranger Power Ranger oh my god oh
my good some of this [ __ ] people do is
your kid is your your daughter into uh
like for the birthdays hiring like a
Power Ranger or a spider-man because my
son was never into that nope
never know the barest it man it drives I
went to a birthday party with my son and
they had a spider-man with like regular
Nikes on key and my son was just that's
what I knew my son was cool he was like
the spider-man have Nikes on but all the
other kids were just buying into it Oh
[ __ ] spider-man
my son was like this far ahead make you
sweat there's always one [ __ ]
kid doesn't know I don't know about this
Saturday
yes yeah is not big on Sam
my son is like hi how you doing you want
to sit on my lap flop me and I saw you
first row at the church the other day I
know what kind of sanding that's right
it's crazy I love that analogy that you
said that because now that I think about
it my heart
no I'm talking about the the seeding
Brooklyn in the in the in the in the
church because literally I'm I'm the one
that sits in the back I sit right in the
back
I'm a sinner yeah I'm a sinner it's
never gonna change I said in the last
few when I go to check those twice a
year I get up on Sunday early at seven
thirty minutes a new couple money yeah
and I got back a look at the glass
yeah glass the 12 steps I love all that
[ __ ] I was raised on that [ __ ] but all
the politics of the church and talking
oh I don't want to be involved
yeah I don't want to be fun no at all
and I like I still wanted it made my
confirmation when I was thirty years old
oh when I got divorced I was like I got
the devil on me
so here I am sitting with 12-year olds
or the confirmation ass every Thursday
afternoons this [ __ ] will shoot all of
your stories high as a kite
kid you shoot your fiery kite with 12
year olds learning about [ __ ] Jesus
this is lucky no I believe I believe in
150% I believe that there's a god yeah I
don't know Jesus came down here fought
the jews hand-to-hand combat yeah I
think it's a little stretched out yeah
but you know what I was always thinking
Joey is uh before the internet before
all this [ __ ] right like I feel like
like Jesus this me just tripping one day
I feel like Jesus was like imagine if
David Blaine was back then imagine David
Blaine back then during the when Jesus
around maybe that too that was because I
right now you see David Blaine you're
like all right Co the internet you know
we know that that's tricks we can go to
like how did he do that calm and it'll
show us but imagine back then when there
was no internet or good I have or how
they do that thing like they got that
one that one magic show where they were
like giving off the magician yeah they
were [ __ ] a box okay yeah you
remember oh yeah that the unmasked
magician giving off all their secrets
and [ __ ] but like imagine before all
that when you know you were David Blaine
and you were showing people all this
this trickery like wouldn't you be like
a prophet dude I mean I mean how old is
magic is older than it's probably older
than Earth you don't mean like it'd be
really think about it you know it's in
the Bible sorcery Wizards and blah blah
blah maybe that was what David Blaine
was maybe he was just a really good he
was a good guy doing some Jesus Christ
stuff do I sound stupid right now no if
you have to look at it from Walter
you got to look at it that way cuz what
your if you look at it like like us
today and I'm say yeah no David Blaine
would not be a prophet but imagine him
doing that [ __ ] back then minds would be
[ __ ] blown you wouldn't even have to
be that good you know how they see
walking on water have you seen David
Blaine stand on that [ __ ] telephone
pole 300 feet for four days without
sleep like imagine doing that back then
you know not knowing any you know I
don't know I've just driven that's the
truth
I can't even you know it's funny I
started doing comedy Wyoming
I started in Denver so wow you were
Eastern Washington you know I started in
Denver so when you don't ever when I
first got out of stages to comedy Wow
then I started getting a few gigs like
in 93 and I would go to like Wyoming
Nebraska and that was my tariff ya know
New Mexico Arizona but like one-nighters
but I don't never been in a summit quite
a while yeah and Tribble had a magician
and they were like what they were
trippin like they would trip it yeah
people were trippin like on the verge of
worship the guy was creepy yeah and then
he had he had kids in the trunk
something wasn't right wouldn't it be
and we enter the hurry yeah yeah and
I'll never forget that night I was like
man those people who I owe me like
they'd laugh they ain't clap they were
like it's like throwing a hypnotist on
that and then one that I'm gonna comedy
club and your ability time anytime
you're about to go up yeah there's like
two or three away from me and you just
focusing on your jokes but you're
listening ya hear what the comic is
saying Jerry Rocha take them off it's
voodoo and I asked him I find those had
a true story I was dying yeah cuz I've
actually seen people react
yeah like in small communities I didn't
know what the [ __ ] yeah I asked me it
was Joey you should have been there
the guy and I only complain during the
whole show he called the cops really
yeah the guy and here's a satan lover
he's doing magic trick so when people
believe in Satan do that type the guy
called the cops on the magician that's
so funny
nine-one-one do you think Satan's on
stage right now the gist is do you
remember now I opened for you know my
sister used to open for a magician that
was the funniest [ __ ] ever
so I'm saying she no she was a solo and
that he hired her just to like MC and
introduce the next bit so when he would
go backstage and change into his next
magic outfit she would sing and then go
are you guys ready for more amazing
Danny or whatever the [ __ ] his name was
it was the old hooters
you know you know where Hooters is Vegas
now yeah that used to be called the San
Remo Hotel and they had just a cheesy
magic show right I hope he's probably a
Fanny or so I'm pretty sure he's gonna
hear that [ __ ] but he had a he she
opened for him it was man we would go
and laugh man my sister's like please
you gotta come watch this people are
[ __ ] amazed by some of the [ __ ] and
it's [ __ ] awful magic and it was it
was awful magic she had there was one
bit where she had to like shove a chow
you know it was the child that has the
black tongue looks like a big blind like
a dog lying right
he would make a child up here and she
was the one that was shoving it through
the curtain and then and then the crowd
go sitting there watching this [ __ ] like
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now but
that was but that was literally a Vegas
show I think it was like an afternoon
show like 5 o'clock she would've can't
get tickets for Wayne no no no they
couldn't get see my boy Wayne Newton so
goddamnit I came home I can't wait to
see his rendition oh my I did it my way
I love seeing people who don't like we I
went to a Christmas party once and Steve
Simone and Joey were there and they've
ran out of the room I'm Catholic oh your
god no I don't want to see magicians
they freak you out make me nervous
I'm a cab he was doing coke disappear
yeah
one way to do that there's only one way
to do that hey [ __ ] I don't know
something about auditioned clowns
they just don't know yeah but Twi'lek
wizkid creepy sometimes yeah yeah
ventriloquist week me and uh great but
they get creepy sometimes yeah II have a
couple friends who became and told
Kristen comedy like yeah I don't think
it's comic so I became retorted they
[ __ ] sell [ __ ] out yeah they sell
[ __ ] out on a Saturday night and the
[ __ ] you know and like all 52 in
Boston
oh yeah is the name of that town cuz I
used to be a comedy club uh-huh but
Saturday night late he had that song
those guy and that guy who's out r-rated
he's a hypnotist already a hypnotist and
he was sounds about Jack really and he's
a nice guy he's a nice guy I met him a
couple of times he's always been very
nice I would open from because as a
feature act you would feature for the
headline that he had three routes yeah
loved 5652 I don't know where this this
is in Boston 15 years ago one sides dead
and buried
what's his name Ron Ron something Salma
Ron DeLuca Ron something like yeah a
comic he said you're never gonna get
into Knicks or the other place to the
big no boomerang comment connection the
comedy connection
yeah but this guy loves LA comics so he
brought me out with Stanhope nice
Stanhope but I would do you did like
seven shows in two days as a feature
Jesus he's knowing 100 a show yeah man
and he would give like a 200 bucks you
could eat lobster do you have lobster
that clam shot or whatever you want he
was selling out like that he had it was
a it's worth Jay Leno's from yeah what's
the name of that town Newton Lowell
Lowell okay so he had like this built in
next next to it is a Puerto Rican town
lot of Spanish people yeah next to it so
he worked off that it was a bad
neighborhood yeah he had a heel he was
word Jalen Jay Leno was from four blocks
away we're gonna cross the [ __ ] road
and you went three blocks he took me
over there and showed me his house so
that's it was Jay Leno hometown he
worked where he where he lived
yeah any love numbers like that he had
club fifty-two
56 there's the what he did oh wait if he
owned it he owned it know what he was
doing was what's it well then namely
he's from and did over and over and over
and ball okay club 56 his hand over mass
so they had a rule if he worked to him
you couldn't work for bill bill lay down
the wall but when you're a feature bill
wasn't gonna work you unless a headline
a break to the comedy connection anyway
yeah those days there weren't really
hiring features why would they bring a
feature and they got Boston's yeah
39,000 features exactly but this guy
brought features it because of that
reason
yeah so he would do seven o'clock in the
run room was Tina and told his ready I
mean he did he went all out
Wow the big room was that Tommy would be
you know Stanhope Rogan or Gabriel or
you and then you would do two shows in
their room mm-hmm so Friday you would do
Worcester gaku a coup a Chinese
restaurant always puke they would drink
those [ __ ] scorpion I know what
you're talking about
we all did it at one time are you
talking about the I know exactly what
you're talking about and then you look
on the tables and they had the the lava
flows I have a flows and people always
puke there so mm it was always a
fistfight
are you serious that was it always that
was Friday nights and then Saturday you
headlined most comics got hit most names
got hit there like without what on
twister
oh we're just fly-in yeah I'm with Chris
Tyler said I don't go Wooster yeah I
only do end over Friday and Saturday
yeah so he would headline he would have
Wooster Friday his club Friday and
Saturday so the whole weekend the guy
would do close to 10 shows Jesus
so one main headline a teen and Tony's
wedding a second main rule show and a
local show and then
midnight was Frank Santos well 11
o'clock was Frank Santos
yeah then a few of those in
Massachusetts the Chinese with the
upstairs is comedy what's great Friday
San Francisco does the think the Jewish
people they hire for Christmas Oh
why do you leave it up
ich coming home just that's funny it's a
comedy show for Jews or the Chinese
restaurant I love it I'd go to that when
you first moved to Vegas yeah it was it
to start now
1989 you know what's crazy that that's
so funny that I'm talking to you right
now because uh steve Schirripa used to
book rip the rib bro the comedy club I
think it was gone
right that was like sandy shores world
right he'd always go up there and I and
I would watch Chimel I would watch
Slayton I would watch I would watch
everybody and mind you I just came from
you know I'm still like 18 you know I
mean so I want to be a comic so I kept
calling he was the only Booker that
would answer the phone like I would call
every comedy club there was a catch
rising star at the MGM but I think it
was the bow its Bally's now but it used
to be called the MGM and then there was
a there was just other comedy clubs
everywhere like Harrah's I think had the
improv I can't remember but I would call
I was just always call you know and then
uh but he was the only one that would
answer the phone the Riviera comedy club
and literally like every other week I
would change my name and go hey I'm a
local comic you know I'd like to do warm
up like five minutes if I could like
emcee you know I'd love to do it but
yeah we already got somebody kid all
right thank you all right pumpkin he'd
hang up man finally after like maybe the
six month after I've changed my name
like a thousand times he was like hey
look kid all right
you're not gonna get in here calling me
everything you need to go to LA you need
to work on your craft and then you're
gonna get an agent and then they're
gonna book you here all right that's
that's all I'm gonna tell you I tell you
he was really nice I was like all right
thank you he's like all right I'll see
you in the future and be hung up and
that was the last time I talked to Steve
Schirripa but that but thank God he did
that cuz I was gonna I literally was
gonna keep calling him until he booked
me and then finally he was just like
that's not how you doing kid I was in
your circle in Vegas nobody there I mean
you know Sam Tripoli all the court
nobody this is before that Tripoli was
like there was a coffee house called
Buzzy's Cafe and it was a copy house
right by UNLV and it was like I can't
remember
all the guys it was rich Sant Sam and a
couple other people that were local
comics that were the Hamill's ever watch
Channel was already like our God you
know well yeah he was kind of like he
already had like he didn't have TV cred
but he was already kind of like doing
his [ __ ] he was are like a name like if
Stanhope was gonna go up that night we
were all kind of like no stand-ups
coming you know I mean you know it is
we're all starting and uh but I didn't
get to meet them until later on I was
kind of like doing like these I did this
thing called star mania which was a
competition that my sister was in and
she was singing and so I started doing
this uh you know I did the stand up
there and I it was a where you gonna
like these local bars and do these
talent shows and they had like a comedy
night you know they had the comedy
portion I I did that I did the the
biggest fool competition at the
Tropicana do you remember the Tropicana
had a girl club there was I forget the
name it's gone out slap factory now
Desert Inn I used to do spawn oh my god
the desert diamond ward oh my god are
you kidding me I got booked one night to
work with a towel one somebody else was
a great week what year was that
98 yeah had it better got a tuxedo I had
to go down the Santa Monica Boulevard
there's a new and use your a secondhand
store on I think
Gardner yeah the corner and I wouldn't
man it was a perfect tuxedo yeah and I
[ __ ] got in there and a towel and the
other guy I cancelled Artie Lange Artie
Lange was Tim Allen yeah and Michael
Jimmy have any favorito that's why I was
working with now that's crazy
I've ever met Tim Allen he was [ __ ]
gracious it was a great weekend that's
amazing what I remember all those little
going out there nobody behind me has to
remember an open mic at the Plaza yes
the plaza being scared you should be big
people don't really know now either they
don't really know that old downtown 8
was scary though yeah man I I did a
couple shows down down there but see
this is before the big dome over old Las
Vegas you know how they have
this big little doll yeah you could zip
line now it wasn't like that back then
man it was you know it was it was a
pretty scary area North Las Vegas
I think the plaza and the Fitzgerald I
didn't know how I remember doing a gig
what I did the thing for Netflix and we
went outside where we stay from that
place Golden Nugget I don't understand
the Golden Nugget that's where we shot
we shot close to that well what did you
do that never forget it had it be 97 the
Canyon Club yeah had a club and it was
like the Hard Rock in downtown and the
guy called me Lance
yeah great guy and he goes hey man I
don't know if it's gonna work I'm gonna
give you a plane ticket a couple hundred
just bring out a friend get your hotel
room at the Golden Nugget and try copy
there was oh really
Bob and Bob suite this was in the Golden
Nugget this was at that club he had okay
whenever the Canyon club is they had a
version of that in Vegas out there
downtown and he was trying the promoter
he had the plasmatic going 11 o'clock
which brought people in yeah he needed
some at night so he wanted to give Tommy
oh my god so for like six weeks we tried
the book and he would fly me and every
Wednesday and I would do that with two
other way you know I think I took
Tripoli one time it was horrible Wow it
was horribly page like a flat 300 it was
you know 13 cream later he would all
know about that old big and I still
remember waiting for a ride from him the
next morning thinking like I'm gonna
have to do something while I am yeah I
finally get on the road I'm finally in
Las Vegas and I'm performing for three
[ __ ] people
oh and then I got into Vegas and I got
into that club with the swords Calver
catch a rising star MGM know before they
wanted to the MGM or I have two left the
MGM yeah it went into the hotel that
they give you swords it's Team Excalibur
I think it was that
and happy Monday through Sunday Joe
cowboy if I didn't get stabbed by a
sword one time I think it stabbed 200
times that's they gave me the keys to
the employee cafeteria
unbelievable another figure picking up a
piece of Turkey and the end had like a
mark with somebody tasted it well hold
it back you have no I like for all
people really don't know I know that
food cafeteria by the way
disappointments yeah when you're doing
comedy you don't tell nobody
nope because you don't want your family
and friends to say you got to quit you
can't live like that no more eat more on
Turkey
this is [ __ ] that you can't help me now
they don't know the grind Rogan brought
me into that Riviera hmm you guys played
the big room with upstairs yeah because
there's two rooms where ice is going
Newsradio up at the top yeah so you get
when yeah Rogan took you to the nice
room advice that's that's where the the
headliners play but I don't even know he
did qualify that has a nice room I know
I wouldn't back then it was I would
offer that yeah and then he went up and
suddenly made a comment about fill cup
so Hartman Hartman yeah he went off in
there yeah so like the set was kind of
weird yeah I wasn't that good but I
don't forget Schirripa gave me the keys
to the employee cafeteria done that
weekend was brutal it was Friday in
Saturday at midnight yeah midnight shows
two x-rated yeah yeah you gotta wait
till midnight I didn't expect that
yeah man - wait no [ __ ] midnight yeah
I've never done that before
yeah like I've been doing comedy eight
years behind years I've got a midnight
show and to wait till midnight I'm like
who does this that's crazy
who are you gonna tell who's gonna say
to you well you should quit you should
look for a different job I was
heartbroken after I did the rib eye
still no going down and they too had
Turkey with stuff and the stuffing was
rot yeah like I'm gonna be eating the
stuffing just drawing it away and going
I can't win I couldn't borrow money from
Joe I wasn't that good of friends with
him like I felt guilty I yeah 20 bucks
to eat like it was just crazy is it that
and you know what's crazy is no one
knows this reference that you're saying
like these kids now don't know that
there was a Riviera
it's gone it's gone
they don't know that the the number one
show at that time was splash that was
the that was the running show that was
at the Riviera and then they had another
what was it was like a it was like
before cirque de soleil it was a variety
show they had guys riding in a in a
metal ball the motorcycles they had
go-go dancers they had jugglers it was
just like this smorgasbord of
entertainment but they called it splash
it was the number one Vegas show at a
time they had like a topless revue yeah
it was called crazy girls yeah
the Riviera was the room at that time
the week we did it that we can't deliver
at rogue you know we did Friday night
and then Saturday before the show we
went down to the bar to meet another
comic who was in Vegas Norm Macdonald
Macdonald Lorne the first guy the one
that invented smidgens oh man or
something norm something he's he lives
in Montana uh-huh he was there so we
went down to meet him and there was a
girl that was a [ __ ] 12 and a body
she was beautiful she was another girl
that she clung on to Rogen yeah awesome
the security phone said Joe Rogan pick
up security next door we asked sooner
because they fired me because I was
transgender so I got a couple drinks
and she's like I can't I go show it to
me I've never seen a transgender little
[ __ ] before just show it to uncle Joey
give me shot in Joe Rogan we were
looking right this she had no panties on
she pulled back the skirt she gave us a
shot let a little bat and it looked like
somebody took a drill bit yeah the hole
yeah it's calling yeah what that thing
is called they held it up and they took
it out they took the pic off they just
cleaned it out and they're like so to
cling on to it
wait really and they just put a piece of
artificial turf like a little it was
like a wig they have him that for [ __ ]
little vaginal wigs have you seen those
now you shave your monkey in order of
vaginal wait Joey this was what year
this is 98 this is like before all the
good surgery we have now yes so she was
like a trendsetter
she was [ __ ] badasses yeah oh and she
was suing the crazy girls and the NBC
had given a developmental deal that's
when reality was going to start being
big and they were gonna show her life
and [ __ ] she could have been lying who
the [ __ ] knows that's the last time yeah
I walked at the Riviera once she gave me
a shot so you don't even know it's you
telling the truth no but she could have
been just showing you a really bad
vagina she was real always real sure rip
I saw it on the security really Rogan
look before you take it to the room or
think she's broken the damaged goods
like don't don't take it to the room by
mistake she's a man that became a woman
beautiful yeah three drinks and a half
gram of coke and me she wouldn't look
down I would have tore that little man
made [ __ ] at life with a couple of coke
rocks in the Cueva though he's you can
blame it on the quaalude yeah no she was
a man that [ __ ] was good
yeah she had ice cubes in her mother
whatever the [ __ ] you want to say it was
[ __ ] crate and it looked like
somebody had opened their mouth and go
you don't want in the commercial in the
cartoon and somebody goes ah yeah they
see the Bell yeah she had one of those
bells hanging like just like a little
[ __ ] Bell that you will apply a gun
did the true story I was the last
[ __ ] you see for how long did she
keep her legs open for a minute
Jesus just showed me the bat
I can't what kind of person would be
[ __ ] educational yeah show at Uncle
Joe is she just took me and Grogan my
house and then I wrote a bit about it
like I was like you know she showed me a
little bat with wings
it was [ __ ] disturbing it was [ __ ]
disturbing but hilarious
but enough with that [ __ ] today that's a
great story man you're bringing me back
to like just what cuz I Vegas was my
that that's where it all started for me
and to hear like you know the Riviera
and you and him shootin the [ __ ] at the
bar like that it's just like that's old
Vegas you know when I told raiga school
I think with minute were you wanted to
change it changed it literally changed
when I left I felt like that was the
tail end of it like I left in oh my god
mm so you know once the wind came in
1990 I think it was 1990 he kind of
turned Vegas it's like a family town and
then they realized that okay this isn't
making any money anymore and then they
went back to sex drugs and rock and roll
Vegas and I think that was right around
2000 so seeing all those monuments go
you know Steve had a lot to do with that
I mean I love Steve Steve Wynn I'm
saying his name like he's my friend but
I love what he did for Vegas cuz I lived
there and my you know my mom and dad you
know lived a good life there because of
that but it sucked because those those
hotels are gone and that lifestyle is
gone that Vegas is gone that that style
of Vegas is gone now what did you do for
a living why you I was I did everything
man I worked at the you know the balls
that were there I the dolphin habitat at
the Mirage I was a tour guide oh my god
I did everything I was at the xcalibur
that's why when you said you weren't
when you went downstairs and said that
uh the break room the cafeteria I used
to eat in that cafeteria I know exactly
what you're talking about yeah I worked
at I was awful man but I mean I always
knew that I was gonna do stand-up
somehow in that city and even if they
weren't gonna book me that's why I
started you know renting out theaters
and selling my own tickets and stuff
like that so I rented out a theater on
Charleston and Maryland Parkway it was
called the hunt roots theater it was an
old movie theater and I would hire
comics to come down and do a comedy
night there but I knew somehow I was
gonna do stand-up in that town that's
why when I finally got the the Wynn
Hotel that just passed like two weeks
ago I was kind of like when I was on
stage I was like you guys don't even
understand where it all started for me I
was on Charleston Maryland Parkway and
now here I am at the wind so dreams come
true it just takes a little bit longer
you know you've been that way since 2000
2000 what made you finally come 2001 I
just you know I had a lot of comic
friends you know tell me you got to get
to LA you know you can only do this for
so long
you can only book these shows that's
only good that's that's that's little
money is what you're doing now it's not
good it's not gonna enhance your career
you're just getting a little money here
and there but if you want your career to
take up you need to move the LA Bobby
was one of them Bobby Lee was the first
one to be like get the [ __ ] out of here
man what are you doing you need to come
to LA in fact Bobby was living in San
Diego at the time he goes I'm moving to
LA that's right
Bobby was living in he was he was like a
house regular at the La Jolla Comedy
Store that's where I met Bobby and then
Bobby was like you know I brought I flew
Bobby out to uh to Vegas and I did this
show at the UNLV the Student Union I
have rented out this hall and had this
comedy night I was gonna push this whole
Asian theme night you know I mean I had
Bobby Lee and myself and another cat
named Mark Fernandez and uh yeah you
remember Warren Sam yeah yeah from San
Diego the nicest I mean are ya there is
he I don't know I I need to get back in
touch with him managed to a guy yeah we
always really nice always you know yup
very sweetheart yeah man oh my god nice
haircut good luck yeah good-looking guy
guys and then we not have a [ __ ] and the
Bobby had the big afro at the time and
he always wore the Hawaiian shirt you
know this is before MADtv and and I flew
him out and I remember at the end of
that weekend he looked at me he was like
you need to move to LA like you can't
stay here like this is not gonna do
anything for you man you're gonna he I
sorta
says it to this day - he goes you could
be shoveling Tiger [ __ ] for the rest of
your life and I'm shoveling Tiger
shuffle I think I was shoveling Tiger
[ __ ] at that time and uh I was I was
doing the tour guide but I mean
basically the same thing I'm working in
some kind of animal habitat you know and
he was right so yeah thank God oh no
this is before the tiger [ __ ] I was
doing something else people at that time
and and Bobby was just like you gotta do
it you know what's crazy is I was on -
uh Bobby's starting I was doing Tiger
belly I'm sorry I keep going all over
the place Joey I'm but uh but you know I
I told - I told Bobby I was like yo man
I don't know if you know this but you
have indirectly motivated me so many
times and I don't think you understand
it cuz you know Bobby doesn't take
compliments everything he's used to [ __ ]
it worse the guy the guy something's
wrong with him mentally and I and I go
you need to hear this bro because you do
motivate people and your words do what
you say really does affect people and
that I told him about that when you told
me that I'll be shoveling Tiger [ __ ]
yeah you were being funny but you know
it hit my heart you know to see you get
back on a plane and go to LA and chase
your dreams and Here I am in Vegas just
trying to try and be a comic you know to
me that like that what you said to me
really motivated me and then there was
this other time where we were pitching a
show in LA and we were sitting in this
we were sitting in the parking lot at
like I think was at MTV you know we were
pitching a show at MTV whatever it is I
don't know what the network was but
anyways we were in the in the parking
lot and we're going over what we're
gonna pitch back and forth right and
then he said something to me and I
laughed but I guess what I was I wasn't
really listening to what he was saying
to me and he got offended by that you
know I mean and then he goes you don't
[ __ ] get it because you don't [ __ ]
get it do you like you [ __ ] wake up
man like it's more than this man it's
[ __ ] more than this and he got out of
the car nice slam the door and I was
like wait a minute I thought we were
just joking for a second but I didn't
know what he was saying was really
serious and uh and I remember that was
the day I made this conscious decision
to like it's not about and basically
what he was saying is
like it's not about the road all the
time and about the money it's about
[ __ ] honing in on your craft and and
and showing the people what you have you
don't I mean I guess and that's what he
said to me in the car he goes it's not
about that it's not about the [ __ ]
road all the time and and making all
your making your money it's about honing
in on this craft and letting people know
that you have this this gift and show
people that that's what this is all
about you know the the show that we were
pitching and he slammed the door on me
and he walked off and he was really mad
and and I think that was the day I woke
up and I was just like whoa I get it now
and I literally did that did wake me up
and it motivated me and and I I changed
my way of looking at the road and and
changed my way and trying to put my mark
in Hollywood and you know I mean you
still a tremendous road warrior did I am
man I am I am every week every week bro
I got to and I and I and I and it's it's
like I always challenge myself it's like
okay like I'll ask the improv how many
did I do last week 16 or I mean how many
did I do last year 16 all right I will
do 17 this year and I'll do it
you know I mean cuz it's like I'm always
trying to up myself I'm on weeks to your
average a year oh man I mean improv
alone I'm doing two weeks back-to-back
I'll do a couple years ago I went to
Cobbs you had two weeks back there back
yeah I go does he go home well does he
stay up here for three days homeless
eases kid yeah I'll go home for like
three days and then come back why were
you doing that instead of doing the
theater at the time monies and cops
money man the cops would pay you more
well it pays more it just does it's not
even Cobbs anywhere at that point it's
me I take over the room and and you just
get more money that way it's just it's
exhausting you know the main but but
that's also what when I was getting it
with uh with Bobby he's like what are
you doing like you know I mean like take
take the take the theater gig and then
concentrate on this you know I mean
audition you know go man and that that's
why I was able to like this special that
might my first special the the live from
Seattle with Netflix I I produced the
whole thing and it was because of Bobby
yelling at me like
you know I mean I'm not saying he's the
one that told me to to produce the
nefeli special but it was it was words
like that that was in the parking lot
that I was like yeah he's [ __ ] right
man like if if it's not gonna happen
then I got to make it happen and and
that's what happened with that first
special like they said no to be in that
police said no to me and and I went and
shot at myself and sold it to him so I
don't think it's a good special one from
Seattle Thank You Man and me laughs they
said no to me Joey they said no to me
like three times and I shot it myself
and it was so crazy because when I was
performing that night in my head I was
saying to myself [ __ ] man the only
person I want to sell this to is Netflix
and they already said no and I had so
much money invested in that that's
special and it's just my life was in
that special man and I and I only wanted
it on Netflix I didn't want it anywhere
else so I got it I was able to sell it
you know what I mean so it was I told
Bobby that when I was on his last when I
went on Tiger but I was like you know
dude you're the reason why man I just
want you to hear that like your words
cut deep and it motivated me sometimes
people got to hear that you did two
shows for Comedy Central I did - I did
don't make him angry and I did lights
out and I and I still feel like lights
out was like like my best really I I
[ __ ] man that was my life right there
live from Seattle live from Seattle I
was hungry man I love life from Seattle
don't get me wrong but I feel like
lights out was just like this turning
point in my career and my son was just
going to a elementary school yeah it was
his his kindergarten and it was just
like the things I was talking about was
just so raw and real and I was just like
I love that special I really do
it kind of hurt me that they shelved it
they never really aired it on Comedy
Central because I really loved it but
but live from Seattle like man yeah yeah
I think you to prepare for life for
Seattle it was so crazy because uh it
was so crazy because I already had an
hour ready after lights out but they
never came back with an offer so I had
to retire all that [ __ ] you know I mean
because my son was too old by that time
if I would if I would have done that on
live from Seattle it wouldn't mean any
sense because it's like my son that was
five years ago it was I think it was
five years in between lights out and
live from Seattle so it's like I went
through like three reached routines by
and then uh and then when like when when
Netflix turned me down I was like okay I
can't keep passing up on these hours you
don't I mean other I got to get this one
this one I need to [ __ ] make it
special so if they don't buy it I'll put
it on YouTube or some [ __ ] but I need
this special now so yeah I you see five
years worth of work right there and live
from Seattle I'm going to cob and seeing
those two weeks and to get them myself
everybody's focused on Louis CK and Amy
Schumer and they kept a high off Joe
Corinne here yes he is creeping why are
you sleeping and always doing killers
and cops you know they either go to a
theater and do it but nobody that's a
lot of tickets two weeks of [ __ ] yeah
that's crazy that's 450 issue they hold
yes 450 yeah [ __ ] six shows a lot of
[ __ ] bodies yeah man I was doing 16 I
was 16 I was doing 8 a week yeah that's
what's going on right now over at Irvine
I'm doing 16 total for two weeks two
weeks total yeah I saw so that's PI
that's right 600 yeah pray on it till
you do like 92 shows Ontario instead of
doing one big show on a [ __ ] arena B
what do you feel I think I think what it
is is I'm so addicted to the interaction
and and the improv like ad-libbing and I
feel what I do the theater is I I stay
in in my little pocket and do my set
more instead of really like and you know
me like being loose I guess and when I'm
at the improv I really just like I don't
know what it is man it's just I'm not
trying to do a routine man I'm literally
just having fun you know I'm just now
during the week you don't want
No why not I think I'm exactly you know
exhausted and they asked me do
everything you do on the road yeah if
you're not on the road you don't do it
yeah but I mean you gotta remember I'm
doing 60 like on Terry I just I did
Ontario 16 shows me after you get off
stage on Sunday don't you feel rusty on
Wednesday ah no I'm ready to go I'm in a
situation right now this is you know
yeah I got a six year old yeah a wife I
enjoy doing this podcast yeah in my
heart I wish I'd go out three weeks a
month but I can't do it yeah too much
two weeks is good enough for me you know
to four weeks to leave is whatever the
[ __ ] yeah look at last week I got
cancelled Saturday Atlanta shut down
couldn't get it out of [ __ ] Atlanta
what happened I got stuck in New Orleans
ah finally got the 722 flight don't get
you into Atlanta - I haven't stayed them
a half hour on the runway in New Orleans
and another 45 minutes in that land and
then I get to our land they lost my
luggage
oh so we had a cancer the tabernacle and
it Brooklyn you know it just breaks my
[ __ ] heart you know like that you
have to cancel people drove five hours
yeah they did all this that's why I
don't like theatres yeah I like going
somewhere Thursday Friday Saturday yeah
I like starting a joke on Friday and
seeing where it ends up on seven but the
agents talked you out of the theatres
out of the club's may say you can make
more money on a single night and forget
like me it makes sense because of my
daughter yeah I get to spend more time
at home I get to go to her things at
three o'clock yeah I get to do those
things yeah
so I'm gonna [ __ ] pickle right now
yeah I'm gonna life pickle if I mean
yeah 100% our gas is the catalyst yeah
this keeps everybody in [ __ ] business
this is what's feeding everybody
so this needs to be done yeah I cannot
do it with a gun to my head you can't go
on with flight leaves at 4:00 I gotta
come with you at 1:00 I got a rush you
not even let you relax and then do a
podcast and do the podcast no one I
gotta get another point yeah I can't do
that no more
yeah I used to do that do shoot a movie
then run to the comedy store and guess
what you [ __ ] up both of them yeah
because old time you should the movie
you're thinking about your stupid set
and you did 90 on La Cienega so now you
think the cops are chasing you when you
get on [ __ ] stage like we're never
gonna get you're not focused yeah you're
not you know so for me number two I
don't think my act is where it should be
I gotta be honest yeah that's where the
improv comes in though if you're not
honest with yourself yeah you never
don't think my act is where I could
charge you that amount of money for
those - yeah you wouldn't feel right on
the field what if you alright yeah I
won't feel [ __ ] right so right now I'm
in a situation where this year was just
to go to a couple theaters see how it
works for me this cancellation Atlanta
did not go well with me you know why
because I'm my first flight out in the
morning guy yeah that first flight is
never the way yeah but I can't fly into
our land at 9:00 in the morning because
they won't let you check into your hotel
so yeah I sit in the lobby with your
dick in your [ __ ] hand yeah they go
to a museum I had time to go to a
[ __ ] Rizzo so this is the dilemma I'm
in this year so I gotta make a decision
for this year I love going to the San
Fran [ __ ] yeah I love going to improv I
have so many great dude weekend's you
just you just made my eyes twitch
witness at Tampa I love Kansas City move
love you know you go to lose man how
about the Omaha funny bone oh my god
that lady is [ __ ] Pauline Colleen you
know you go to these places they're your
home but then somebody comes to you
insist what if I could not 5000 off that
you get less money but it's only one
night I can live with that yeah I'd
rather fly Thursday get a good steak and
do Friday more you get a Friday if you
got radio you do it if you saw that you
still do it you know people with air for
you and you or someone tickets yes the
only people there for you when you want
tickets so the weekend sold that go down
there so take you two hours to the nine
and twelve you smoke on the way back you
stop at CVS and get some time for your
nuts yeah yeah I always forget that oh
don't do talcum no don't don't do tell
come my ovaries my nut should be ready I
mean by powder unless it said talked
about
my dad said talcum and I can't see what
women toplin pilot was this [ __ ] yeah
when I was growing up in the eighties a
woman who didn't put talking Potter on
their monkey she was slipping Jack no it
kept it like a turkey they kept it dry
on the outside nice and juicy on the
inside but not women the diet thing
about the turkey comment yeah not women
a diet right or wrong when you take
saran wrap on Thanksgiving you put
outside the turkey right keep some
turkey [ __ ] no it makes sense that
he's never thought of a monkey what made
you shoot this masterpiece that's coming
out oh why oh why
I know as anybody ever shot a special
Hawaii I don't know nothing so I think
Elvis was the last one to shoot a
special holy [ __ ] Angela Johnson Oh
Angela Johnson yeah
she shot hers Gabriel a few years ago oh
that's right Gabriel yeah no [ __ ] yeah
how big was that arena this one I sold
four arenas oh yeah man I think we sold
close to 24,000 tickets Jiro's it was
crazy I don't know there are 24,000
people on that's what they said they're
like Brad I we didn't even know brah
Josh said they gave me like Hawaiians
day they Deanna came I own day I really
[ __ ] Kempo they said [ __ ] camp all
day kept doing this yeah mother [ __ ]
brought people from all over the south
it's different yeah the fishermen
Samoans going up there's no babies
Quatro babies when they got Guamanians
oh my job and everybody there when Joe
Milosh is telling me [ __ ] was your
managers yeah yeah he's great with all
my heart he uh he was like Joey you just
wouldn't [ __ ] believe it
it's crazy they came from Walla [ __ ] no
how do you feel now I wanted to cry that
night that night was overwhelming we're
gonna play in on Sunday and say to
yourself what the [ __ ] I do every Sunday
I got on a plan I put my earphones on I
know what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I and
it's hard to even explain it to anybody
right Joey you ever have a meeting with
like the people your
you like your team your agency managers
your publicist and then you just sit
there while you're eating you're like
should I pay all these people you know
it's crazy it's even crazy to put your
finger on that because it's not it's not
uh you know I it's not even it's not
even easy explain to somebody else I
mean that this is my my payroll I'm
responsible for this right here if I
[ __ ] up and I'm not funny they they're
gone it's over with and it's hard to
explain that to someone like my mother
or or or my mom that that's not in this
business and and realized that that's
that's my reality you know and on top of
that I still have to take care of my
mother and my son and my sister and
everybody else he's married
no I'm not you have a baby's mama but
yeah and I take care of her you know a
relationship oh it's amazing
[ __ ] to me I've moved her right next
to me every time she says something just
throw a yardstick dude shut up yes
no she's half Filipino half white like
me and I move her right next to my house
literally my son can go he can walk to
his mom's house in less than four
minutes and I told her that I was like
no matter how successful I get you I
will take care you don't have to go get
a lawyer you don't have to do anything
like the more successful I get you will
be compensated I will take care of you
don't worry about it I'm not gonna let
my son live that life you know where
he's Oh dad's got all this and then he
goes back to Mom's house like I'm not
gonna do that like it we're gonna be
you're a great mom
you're taking care has such an ideal I'm
very fortunate I always say that
somebody took care of me up there yeah
whenever I leave the house I go God
whoever took care of me
they can't my daughter the same way yeah
teach me how to make a right instead of
making a left yeah and like I always am
very thankful when you and I came from a
very thankful career we worked hard we
also got our own ticket yeah I totally I
used to do and Boulder your Vegas was my
boat bro that's crazy Chinese restaurant
Babu a guy five foot two his name was
Ron all he cared about was money I want
money I want money you make money you
you we do business we do
honey why did the comedy show on that he
saw a mobile team or he sold more about
my guys than he ever sold his life yes
he would call me every day when we do
come again when we do comedy and I found
that he would say to me can I talk to
you
how much fun Richard Pryor this is a
real conversation oh yeah here we go how
much for Bill Cosby
10,000 give me 500 now let me call his
manager let me go get 500 he'd give me
500 his his nights off on Monday I would
get any black guy to bump into I take
him to the Chinese restaurant I go was
run right now hit telling my brother
Kyle no God be I'm I got all the Chinese
people how's it stopping Bill Cosby
creep and then I go in there on Tuesday
go run what the [ __ ] were you last night
Bill Cosby came I miss them you do that
to me hey Murphy give me 500 Murphy's
have it Monday night I'd show up with a
Murphy some black kid didn't look like
any Murphy and I go in there Tuesday get
another nickel this one on four years
every I mean how about a fluffy fly
tomorrow I'll have him here this Friday
we sell 300 tikkun I made special and
then Monday I'd show up again when this
day's long sheet and I'm one day
actually showed up with somewhere I go
that's he wanted the guy from Monday
Night Football rich the guy that [ __ ]
up Monday Night Football what his
brother owns the cap city really nice
rich Miller
Dennis Miller Dennis Miller had
Monday Night Football oh my god he did
one day he came to me cuz I want Dennis
Miller he funny guy I'll get him here
next week I showed up on a Monday with
some white guy he was there that night
that night Dennis Miller you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I want my money back for
Bill Cosby I want my money back for
Eddie Burke oh I had Lenny Bruce in
their mother's bum yeah anybody he
wanted I would bring him yeah easy acts
with the black ones because I you know
in Chinese people's eyes all blacks less
the same surprise use the same black guy
every time my god you cannot believe
this one on he had a beautiful Chinese
across my place called mustards last
yeah I go spy with pickles and where's
this ed Boulder Colorado oh my god this
is a real story it's a real [ __ ]
story well I don't want to leave here
Joey you're that [ __ ] of self what oh my
god hilarious like this is really and
you know five thousand for Jesus every
week to do coke with me a run well you
want this week I'll bet your prize funny
guy he lit himself on fire he's half
Chinese now be be in two weeks are
having here tonight show up on a Monday
I told you Friday Monday nobody comes to
restaurant we don't need to sell me on
Mondays you paid ten thousand that's a
Monday night you won't Friday like that
cost you all it does and I'm waiting for
him to give me a that Bobby he only sent
160 people never [ __ ] the question we
didn't give a [ __ ] bastard we'll make
our money back in food and I had another
brother who was working on my me on cuz
he loved Nia yeah Chinese people love me
on so he wanted wonton soup in the end
what do you mean me on me up that you
press like open side open side so my
buddy who's don't one who put me out
don't cuz he was working him for years
he was opening Chinese she was [ __ ] up
the letters and come back and hit him up
for another deposit it was crazy we were
mugging rather a daily oh my weekly
[ __ ] face no wonder he needed so much
money you said he'd come bring soup in
there well he did great [ __ ] business
there everything was in neon
dumpling soon he wanted everything in me
he was so [ __ ] crazy open now happy
hour
buffet bar he wanted everything like he
wanted a light over his bar was call
white I don't know Confucius something I
really did there's nothing there now
he's gone I have not been there in 15
years to see what's I've been to bold
but not on that side it's towards the
college just right up the bottom from
the University so I think it's it's a
rapaho Whole Foods so it was like a look
he has like a new restaurant with like a
wall of fame of just black people but
it's like he says oh that's Bill Cosby
that's Richard Pryor I am
like I was saying you have the perfect
career like the way you came up you did
you you did your apprenticeship in Vegas
you rented out your own [ __ ] rooms
you sold tickets then you came to LA you
went to the Laugh Factory
yeah man a factory god I used to hand
out cards out front all day every set
yeah man I would hand out cards left her
you know what's crazy Joey's I was doing
a show and the girl's name is Mindy she
dm's me all the time but uh she came to
a show and she's one of those people
that kept my card that I handed out
outside of the Laugh Factory along with
like a DVD that I made that I burnt
myself in my room in my living room and
she still had that copy and I was like
what the [ __ ] you still held on to that
so she had so it's cool to actually see
that that it's still to this day it's
still making its mark for me that I my
hustle my drive you know what I mean I
was handing that [ __ ] out and you're
serving an apprenticeship with Carlos
you showed you open for a couple be bro
that was crazy yeah big crowd yeah if
you learn a lot a lot who were ready
what the 10-year mark you can handle it
out those audiences and how was that it
was the same apprenticeship I had under
Joe Rogan yeah he's crazy like the chef
you know hey show sold out fear factor
people everywhere and you're like the
[ __ ] feature act yeah
which eyes wide open and they're just
and he's handing it to you that's the
beautiful thing that Joe did for you
like here you know and that's that's
something you got to learn how to accept
like you know appreciate that he's
handing that to you and you take
advantage of it you're not taking
advantage of it but it's he's giving you
an opportunity to shine and you and you
shine right like this is his weeks
you're like what you don't even know
what's going on yeah oh I understand
what I have to do now yeah you
understand your job you know yeah I find
myself what I do on the road 60% of the
times it's what I learned with Joe I
wouldn't do when I wasn't him like when
he would call me and say let's go to the
gym and I'm gonna do by yourself
yeah on vacation yeah yeah we thought it
he won't father pounds smoking
cigarettes in the [ __ ] room that's
crazy and he's down there lifting
weights and you why would
weights on the road who does this that's
who works out on the road you go on the
road to [ __ ] go to orgies what can
each I'm yeah that's what I did and then
you like oh she now you're there so yeah
you know we were talking about before
the podcast you want to smoke pot you
know people come up to you and give you
a hug after the hug they tell you my
kids just got out of the hospital they
all had the pneumonia for a week and
you're like thanks yeah I got a meeting
with ABC on Wednesday I guess I'm not
making that [ __ ] it does you wanna
[ __ ] hug me and breathe on my neck
and tell me what about the people at
armpit Ola oh you have an armpit you
take a show I love people I love humans
I love taking pictures of people but I
had to stop taking pictures of people in
between the first and second yeah
because I would get armpit on my neck
and then you gotta go on stage with that
armpit like you try to wash it off with
that oh yeah how about wet hand ah man
that's why I hand don't bother me wet
hand bothers my back boiled my hands
after what I put as hot as I can and I
leave my hands under there I put the
germ stuff like two minutes on a pen I
just boiled my [ __ ] yeah in between
the crevices bananas flu germs develop
what about your kid when he was four or
five and you taped every time I shake my
daughter's hands my whole central
nervous system collapses collapsed cuz I
know she's got every form of [ __ ]
influenza huh [ __ ] everything every
time she today she went to that Park and
came in and tried to hug no I saw you on
that monkey ball yeah that's got more
[ __ ] germs on it for the men's
[ __ ] latrine and I spelled my
daughter's hair after school it's like
what you've been lighting fires did you
hear what happened
no what happened Tokio down he tried to
arson it what I do Japanese people try
to commit arson this is the third
Japanese person well that's five years
that's not gonna burn down me and
Ralphie walked into a restaurant once we
cigar every day Helen wasn't hot there's
gotta be 50 banging yeah she would come
over to the table and talk to us was
all-you-can-eat sushi I've been Ralphie
and man they were all [ __ ]
yeah all their heads and [ __ ] we would
like written $22 or you can eat for
lunch we would kill ya just on the album
or just on the album yeah yeah yeah well
don't wanna Lankershim over here the
cross in the haha right it's [ __ ]
mediocre sushi that they have mussels
with cheese on them because they only
give you four yeah I would go there and
say [ __ ] do you want spider oh [ __ ] you
knows you're a [ __ ] mussels and they
got sick of bringing me mussels they
stop money with it make it long story
short but they live that place on fire I
can tokyo douse he got beat up by the
guy that owns Joe's coffee my Muay Thai
teachers showed me the video today on
the news I didn't see that cuz the guy
didn't pay rent for nine out of ten
months and then he kept telling him like
he kept [ __ ] with the landlord and
[ __ ] the smoothie place went down well
in a smoothie place I told ya we just
went to that the [ __ ] acai in the
sugar done Tokyo does done Joe's Cafe
with Bill burr you should do comedy the
guy Fast Times at Ridgemont High the guy
that's Damone yeah on the first these
Friends of Bill so bill would do comedy
there god burnt holy [ __ ] that is a big
hole fly-fishing yesterday what the [ __ ]
were you here that's what you job it I
live near Lancashire it was shut
yesterday I did not know this till this
morning I gotta see this who the [ __ ]
burn something down in place you got no
excuse you got nowhere to go
I had a fire I don't know what fire you
told me when did you lie the [ __ ]
match absolution yeah he burnt it down
he tried to arson oh my god knows
there's videos every day
I'm chasing the yellow is that the guy
that shot David [ __ ] like these I'm
still in critical condition they broke
his legs oh they got him
the gotta show these would be
accomplished how that world news tonight
they said when we got to the accomplice
he couldn't say much those Dominicans
feed the [ __ ] out of him beat the [ __ ]
outta Jo koy it has been a pleasure
ah man you always have family here
it's called coming out hot yeah coming
out [ __ ] high heaven in Hawaii
my ass [ __ ] Elvis oh but you know
when you said Elvis you have to look
that up do you remember that I used to
watch that left and right so I was the
most viewed pay-per-view till 10 years
ago something broke the record I just
saw it maybe too much go on TV that they
said well it was an HBO documentary I
know if it's part one in part I gotta
watch this when they said uh when he
came back when they realized he was done
they said one last thing then he do well
he did a live remote from Hawaii that
was paper viana and it was the biggest
you know I showed they showed Hawaii and
they showed like wires where countries
well it was [ __ ] amazing everybody
got that bet yeah I love that that was
one of my favorite things to watch when
I was a kid my mom loved that special I
loved Elvis and I loved Elvis this movie
which we don't all play no more which
one
they don't blame him oh yeah they don't
I always had a nice a week no miss week
and Gidget Gidget goes to why huh get
you gets her a seat yeah there's always
a Gidget movie guess what yes did you
get you the truck in without a will huge
yeah
and now they don't show you Elvis we
they don't this is the [ __ ] that
sudamerica you know one of the
hardest-working guys thinking to come in
this office all the success you have is
due to you you're sincere you're a good
friend you helped a lot of people and
you make those [ __ ] it's you and PAC
yeah baby I love that patios on the way
out is you I'll take one of my own
whenever I go to Marcy god parents you
know they they have like they have like
five different things every year yeah
well they just put the mother in for
dementia but definite where she's from
they own the blockbuster
yeah they own a body called the Mike
Mercy's godmothers parents came to this
country from the Philippines he was a
janitor she was like an office work and
they worked hard they bought a [ __ ]
franchise
when blockbuster paid all the whole
family kicked in yeah everybody threw in
20 yeah and they all chipped in on a
blockbuster and that's how they got
their money they sold blockbusters and
once they sold it they got that money
they're very interesting people they
loved that little girl yeah but one time
I went over there and my wife they're my
healing Joey's a comic everybody this is
what I asked my [ __ ] joke boy going
off forget about it
Filipinos put on air like Pacquiao sang
karaoke K yeah that mother [ __ ] that was
all eyes from here to [ __ ] Omaha
Nebraska to see him sing is that real
that's real is real don't go see him
play basketball
oh he would fight and do a party
afterward the tickets tell him you're
100% right and he had any memory had the
tape over his right eye
Oh reside have you thought about doing a
tour with Pacquiao just taking over a
shadowbox yeah yeah for like an hour
yeah what's his why we time I hit my
punch like he just throws like a wife is
the original Beyonce who is wife what's
her name like every Filipino knows is
what you think
Pacquiao's wife has a name yeah every
Filipino knows I'm a bi you go to a
Cuban sighs I got a picture John F
Kennedy with a bullet hole in it thank
you
jinke it every Filipino woman wants to
be like Genki I want to be a Miss Jackie
but most milk in Filipino is called a
biggie yeah you're fukijama [ __ ] but
you're the pride of the Filipino and you
were sweetheart of a guy now wish you
nothing but success and I know from
watching live at Seattle this one's
gonna be [ __ ] super teen thank you so
much please tomorrow night [ __ ] to
watch this whatever the [ __ ] you
downloaded whatever the [ __ ] you need to
do just go to Netflix you'll be on the
first page
tonight at midnight yeah last night at
midnight you'll be on the first page and
it watch the special I'm gonna watch it
tomorrow because my wife leaves for
Tennessee so I'm alone I can watch
specials I could finish watching [ __ ]
Anthony Jeselnik like specially going
you that I have a watch but I appreciate
you coming here and you've always got to
hold me I know yeah yeah I still do his
often arm and you have yours I got mine
the koi pond yeah do that every week can
you do it one time just call yeah I love
you just got Milosh call me I'll have
Miss America yeah yeah thank you dude
you're the best man thank you Joe so
this week you wear um no I'm taking I'm
taking time off with this one
how much time you know I'm taking uh
just this week and then and I'm at UH
Thunder Valley and uh San Diego Thunder
Valley is crazy man that's like an
outdoor venue it's like 6,000 or
something like that it's crazy I don't
know how people stand in the [ __ ]
heat to watch it's in the desert man you
did 20 years of work they come to see
that 20 thank you man
so I guess at any time you want to come
on you want me on your back yeah just
call brother was a pleasure having you
play love you Joey good luck what can
they find you Jay okay oh why that's
everything dot-com Instagram Twitter Jo
Keawe all right I want to thank my man
jo koy I want to thank the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank the
sponsors we'll have our back year round
let me talk to you about something
wiping your butt with dry toilet paper
does not remove all this [ __ ] if you got
poop on any part of your body would you
just wipe it off with dry paper no water
cleans better than dry paper my friends
thankfully there's now a new sleek bidet
attachment that clips onto your existing
toilet and sprays your butt completely
clean with fresh water
it's called pushy and it's the best
thing you could do for your little
[ __ ] filthy muffler okay
pushy sprays fresh water into your
[ __ ] to take away all the yuki eyes
the itchy ass holes the skid marks East
infections hemorrhoids that's what - she
does for you what wipes are worst for
the environment than toilet paper
they're terrible for you
and they call [ __ ] they cause [ __ ]
anal fissures you don't want that type
of [ __ ] anus fishery do you so go -
hello - she calm right now
think up a day starting at [ __ ] $69
and they run with a sixty I think a
ninety day back guarantee but let me
tell you some bleep how long have you
had your bad day for years
I've had mine for years there's your big
ass cracking no neither does mine so
that's just goes to show you it's
[ __ ] quality we both got
[ __ ] bidets I don't know about
Lee's neck below his [ __ ] smoke tip
top Magoo why cuz he's got the hell old
[ __ ] birthday right now they got a
Father's Day bungled excludes includes a
cushy bidet to upgrade your toilet to a
porcelain [ __ ] throne for a king
don't you want that for your father
it comes with bamboo bum tiles made of a
hundred percent bamboo fibers at Uchee
travel case go you could take your
little tushy [ __ ] anywhere and also
you gotta ask my butt t-shirt that you
know your father's got a sense of humor
all these items bundled together I'm
gonna give them to you for a hundred
twenty five hours to dead if your dad's
not working on in twenty five hours
you're a sack of [ __ ] so do me a favor
go - hello - she calm right now
Preston Church and get 10% off your
order do you look forward to pooping get
your [ __ ] tushy you're gonna [ __ ]
run home to take the [ __ ] because when
that little water hits your [ __ ]
there's no better feeling in the stand
break we could talk to the eyes of green
go to hell - she calm right now go look
at the great selection of the days they
got starting at $69 you see something
you want - dad hook them up alright it's
[ __ ] Father's Day you know don't
[ __ ] stop being such a [ __ ]
cheapskate so go - hello - she calm
right now press in church and get 10%
off your order for dad you're not doing
it for yourself do it for that get him
every day and get yourself when you've
been looking like a stinky ass
[ __ ] yourself the church is also
brought to you by on it when it comes to
supplements this is my company I've been
working with them for seven [ __ ]
years and I tell you what from the
protein powder to that old chocolate
powder used to add that tasted cacao
whatever the [ __ ] it was to the Schrute
export the shroom tech immune they have
to DMT I'm not the MP that oil that you
put in your car in your coffee and
morning with NZT MCT listen on it is the
leader in [ __ ] and supplements how do
I know cuz I [ __ ] live at
[ __ ] the Alpha brain is their
flagship product if you if it doesn't
work for you if you don't like it don't
give you a hundred percent money-back
guarantee and they don't want the
product back who else does that nobody
you filthy [ __ ] animals go to audit
calm right now I can't help you with the
kettlebells in the club bells but as far
as the supplements are concerned I got
your back gold on it calm right now
press in church on the way out to get
ten percent off your order delivered
right the house
I want to thank hello tushy I want to
thank on it most importantly I want to
thank you guys for having my back do not
forget this Saturday night I am at the
ice house comedy club and another 29th
and 30th I'm at the Columbus
[ __ ] funny bone I'm still
waiting for a makeup date for Atlanta
I'll keep you guys posted because we're
looking for a Saturday so all you guys
that drove could still come out to the
show you know I appreciate you with all
my heart and I'm very sorry about what
happened with Delta Delta make that
everybody's happy you can't control the
weather stay black you bad [ __ ]
I'll be at the ice house Saturday night
and the Columbus funny bone on the 29th
and 30th get your [ __ ] tickets
that's it I want to thank Jo koy I want
to thank the [ __ ]
I don't want to thank you [ __ ]
for being loyal and for giving us a shot
for listening every week stay black have
a great week we'll see you Monday
morning tip top [ __ ] Magoo kick
this [ __ ] melee